I'm Peter,
I'm founder and CEO of line too.
That's a great question.
I think the first thing is don't quit
your day job until you've done real
diligence on the idea.
And what I mean by that is,
is really look at the market,
look at where the market is headed,
look at the trends,
look at the competitive landscape and,
and try to play a few strategic moves
into the future to see is this something
that's ultimately going to be dominated
by x big company or why big company.
That's not always a reason to say no,
but it's certainly something you want to
look at.
And then,
um,
and then make sure you have a business
model and you know,
how you're gonna make money and then,
you know,
bounce it off.
A few smart people,
but not too many.
Um,
people you really trust.
But we'll be honest with you.
And if it passes all of those tests,
then you should ignore everyone else
that tells you it's a bad idea because
you will hear endlessly from people that
are naysayers or don't understand it and
haven't researched as well as you have
at that point.
Who will say,
no,
that's not possible.
And here's why,
and I'm part of being an entrepreneur is
that as long as you've done that initial
diligence and you've convinced a few
smart people and you all agree that this
is an opportunity,
then you've got to just believe that to
the very end and,
and,
uh,
because you will get a lot of days where
you start to second guess yourself and
where,
uh,
people are telling you that is not a
good idea.
Now I'll qualify that with,
um,
the key to startup success and why they
succeed,
where big companies don't,
is that they can turn on a dime and the
whole process of a,
I can take you through how we started
lying to slash talk to me.
But the whole process is,
um,
it's really about test and measure,
test and measure in a sense.
I mean,
yes,
we all hear about um,
you know,
there's the facebooks of the world and
there's the googles and they're these
massive home runs and,
and everyone sort of thinks that,
you know,
I just put up a website and if I get
lucky and do the right things,
it's going to take off,
but very few businesses are created that
way and that's,
it's,
it's sort of like in the movie business,
there's only you can count the major
stars on,
on,
on two hands and everybody else's
working their ass off.
And not that they don't work either,
but it's a little easier for him maybe.
Um,
and so the trick is you don't have to
risk a lot of capital upfront to learn
things.
So the way we do it is,
and you don't have to get it right,
but you get it out.
There is the trick.
Get something out there.
If you sit and stew and try to make it
perfect and nothing ever gets out there,
you can be too cautious.
So the trick is get it out there and
then iterate,
get feedback from customers.
And that's what we've been doing.
We got the first version of our product
out in February of 2008.
And um,
we,
we did,
didn't do much to promote it.
We just,
we got 50,
70 Beta customers and then we iterated
on what they were telling us,
what they like about it,
what didn't they like about it,
what features are missing,
what do they want to see?
And we iterated for nine months until we
were comfortable to actually start to
put marketing money behind it.
And um,
and there's a lot of learning that,
that,
that is you have to be receptive to.
So,
um,
it's,
it isn't really sort of this,
you know,
put it out there,
build the field,
and they will come,
which is really has a whole other aspect
too is once you've got the product
right,
the real challenge is attracting
customers to it.
It can be a fantastic,
insanely great product,
but if you can't get the word out and
acquire customers cost effectively so
that you have a business model and can
make money.
It doesn't matter how nice a product it
is.
I have always wanted to start a
business.
I've always felt that a running my own
company was really the best place for
me,
the best home for me for a lot of
reasons which we can go into.
Um,
and um,
typically I'd look at different
opportunities and see what,
uh,
you know,
could pan out and the trick is to be
very hard on yourself when you're first
thinking of an idea and talk to smart
people to make sure that,
um,
you kind of vet it out.
Um,
and then the first one was,
um,
typically you want to solve a problem.
Right?
And the problem I had was that I liked
wine,
but I would go into a wine store and I
had no idea which one was good in which
was in,
which is still a problem today.
So you could rewind spectator,
other,
uh,
magazines to learn about wine.
Um,
but then you could never find the wines
that they were talking about.
And so there was a mismatch between the
ability to learn about a wine and then
act on that information to make a
purchase.
And Wine Shopper was my first company,
which was a site that combined the
ability to buy wine with the,
uh,
information,
um,
including ratings from wine spectator
and wine enthusiast and other agencies,
reviews community and all of this.
And this was 1999.
It was a bubble company.
I,
it was funded by Kleiner Perkins and
Amazon Dot com raise $46,000,000 and
built a 200 employee company very
quickly.
And uh,
ultimately,
um,
learned some painful lessons in terms of
access to capital and how quickly that
can dry up.
Um,
the company was ultimately acquired by a
competitor,
um,
and uh,
but that competitor did not survive.
So that my first sort of big venture
kind of deal,
good experience,
lots of learning,
but nobody made any money on x one
called Masonic was,
uh,
I started,
you know,
I was pretty upset for a little while
and then I realized that,
you know,
um,
you've just got to pick yourself up and
dust yourself off.
And that's entrepreneurship is really
like sales and that,
you know,
it can,
you get a lot of discouragement along
the way and you have to be really strong
and just keep going.
So I just got right back up on the
horse,
started a company called [inaudible],
which is now profitable and growing
nicely,
still private.
I'm on the board,
so that one's a wait and see,
I'd say,
um,
uh,
then I started a company called Taleo,
which was a,
um,
a white label version of skype if you
know what skype is,
I think most people do by now.
And um,
that was very lucky timing and was
acquired by Microsoft,
um,
within 18 months of its being founded.
And um,
I didn't want to work for Microsoft,
so I signed a noncompete,
uh,
took a year off and traveled and then
started my latest venture line to also
known as talked to me.
Um,
but I'm line to is really a,
a,
um,
solution for where business is headed
today in terms of the way people work.
If you think about,
um,
landlines,
you know,
more and more people are saying,
why do I need a landline?
And they're getting rid of them and
they're sticking to their mobile phone
and there's some problems with that
because it doesn't always work in your
home and there's battery life issues and
stuff,
but a lot of people getting rid of
landlines,
we believe,
um,
with line two,
the same thing is happening in the
office environment,
particularly small businesses.
You don't really need an office where
everyone has to drive their car in and
park in order to be productive anymore.
You have all of this technology that you
can use the Internet and communication
technologies to be productive virtually.
So lying to basically a is a business
line on your mobile phone.
It's a second line so you add a second
line to your mobile phone.
That's why it's called line to that has
all the features ultimately that that
office phone had no transferring calls,
setting up conferences and stuff like
that.
And so we've just released it.
It was approved by Apple,
um,
in early September.
And sales have been very strong.
I think there's a lot of need for that
and ultimately the problem we're solving
is that people want to work and be
productive,
but they don't want or need an office
and they don't want to be tethered.
There's no,
I mean,
people don't,
even,
everyone's using Wifi.
There is,
there's not even a jack in,
into which a plug and office phone in
most office environments for new
companies.
So that's what we do.
So long answer to your question,
to sort of give you a,
of each business,
it's always about trying to solve a
problem.
Very important.
Um,
we,
I was skeptical at first and uh,
I still scratch my head about twitter,
but I now uh,
uh,
I mean,
I,
it's,
it's here to stay,
you know,
it's one of those things that it's a
self fulfilling.
It became popular because it became
popular.
I don't know how to describe it,
but,
um,
uh,
at any rate,
we,
I,
the guy that does my marketing is
religious about that.
So for example,
uh,
there's a lot of cool tricks.
So we,
one thing,
there's a lot of stuff that,
um,
that's important.
And one of them is you need to blog.
And I was like,
why do I need a blog?
Part of it is,
is if you have constantly changing
content on your website,
so the blog has to be on your website.
Then a search engines reward that.
So like a new site or sun,
constantly changing content.
So if you put up a website and do
nothing with it,
you'll slip down.
If you keep changing the content and
making that content relevant to the
service that you offer and the types of
customers you're trying to attract,
you'll start to go up and natural
search.
The other thing that you do is,
and once you blog a post,
this is where the social media comes in,
post a blog entry,
then you tweet it and you post it to
Linkedin,
facebook,
everywhere,
um,
and two different groups.
And,
and,
and then what happens is this magic
thing happens where it just gets,
it reverberates through the web.
It's really fascinating.
And so one blog post suddenly translates
into multiple hits and those hits are
all then linking back to your blog post.
And that means you're getting more links
into your website,
which as you probably know in search
engine optimization,
that's another thing that's very
important is to generate links back to
your site.
So,
um,
I was sort of dragged kicking and
screaming.
But now I'm a true believer.
It really does work.
There's a lot of companies offering
phone service obviously.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
we are,
our differentiation is our focus and I
think this is important important lesson
for all startups is that,
um,
we,
we have a lot of people because we only
charged 1490 $5 a month who ask us if
they can hook up a Ata,
which is what vonage provides it,
which is a little box that you plug your
phone into.
One end is the internet.
The other end is the phone.
They want an Ata.
But I know from looking at vonage and
other companies that the biggest support
expense for those companies is that Ata,
because getting people to get under
their desks and play with their routers
and hook that thing up,
it's a pain and everyone practically
needs a customer support person holding
their hand through the process.
So it's very expensive.
And um,
so we're like,
yes,
our customers,
there are customers that are trying to
drag us in that direction,
but we are razor focused on our belief
that the future is not about wired
phones,
that the future is about mobile and
laptop calling.
So it's like skype and your mobile
phone.
So what does business phone service look
like in a world of skype and mobile
phones and that's what we're laser
focused on and we're the only ones
positioned that way.
And by being that focused,
um,
it just makes everything better.
One,
you can communicate your position to the
market in a much more laser focused way
so that you can actually stand out as a
brand.
That's an interesting question because,
um,
we are increasingly getting consumers
who come to us and um,
so the line to app as I talked about
earlier,
particularly young people that are like
a landline,
why,
you know,
why does it make sense for me to buy a
phone wire to a wall in particularly
young people because they're moving from
dorms and apartments and many
apartments.
It just makes no sense and you can't
even,
uh,
use it most of the time because you're,
you're out and about and what have you.
So what's the point?
So,
um,
people want to get rid of their
landline.
The problem is some can't because either
they don't have cell phone reception at
home,
um,
or you know,
they talk a lot and they don't want to
wear down the battery though,
you know,
there's all sorts of reasons.
And so,
um,
you can use line to the current version
works over cellular,
but the version coming out in a couple
months,
we'll work over cellular or over Wifi
and that's going to be the first dual
mode thing on your iphone,
on the smartphone,
on the market.
So in the US,
so like skype can only work over Wifi,
it can go over broadband.
So bottom line is a,
excuse me,
you can't go over cellular.
Skype only works over a wide,
so on the iphone.
So if you can,
this now gives you way to ditch your
landline.
So long answer to your question,
but you could use a line to number as
your landline substitute.
You can use it over Wifi when you're at
home and you don't have cell phone
reception,
you can use it as sort of the number you
give out to everybody else,
not the number.
You're best friends have your cell phone
number,
but you know your bank people and credit
card companies statement.
You know anyone billing anyone where
they asked for your home phone number
that you're doing business with or or
something and you don't want to be
bothered on your cell phone.
You do that on your line to number and
then you have all these controls where
you can say,
let certain people through,
depending on the time of day,
who they are,
whether they're friend,
whether business,
different greetings,
depending on who they are.
Um,
you can do all this stuff to sort of
make it a much more of a tool rather
than a nuisance.
Which I think Mike,
my landline phone at home,
I never answered anymore because it's
all spam.
It's,
it's even though I'm on the do not call
lists and have been since I started it.
People,
I don't know where they get my number,
but every call I get is some kind of
marketing call.
So it's,
it's useless.
I mean constant.
That's how you learn.
Right?
And what's nice about silicon valley is
that it rewards that.
Well,
no,
let me take that back.
Um,
it doesn't reward that it tolerate it
more than I'm a large enterprise where
mistakes can be career ending in an,
a really bad company where they,
you know,
where it's a fear,
typically a,
a corporation that's run on fear versus
encouragement and sticks rather than
carrots tends to be an environment where
mistakes are not tolerated and then no
innovation happens.
And so silicon valley's the opposite.
It,
it encourage you to take risks and,
you know,
entrepreneurs are not rational business
people.
I mean,
if you look at the risk and reward
curves,
we're way out here.
We're taking a lot of risk for,
in the hopes of a lot of reward,
but it's not really rational.
You actually,
most business people are much closer to
the,
uh,
the origin there where there's some risk
and some reward but not the kind of
risks that entrepreneurs take.
So,
um,
you know,
the mistakes I've made in taking those
risks have been numerous.
And,
uh,
you know,
there are wine shop or obviously we were
burning $3,000,000 a month and before we
even had customers.
And that was,
you know,
the dog food that everybody's eating
back in or the Koolaid that everybody
was drinking was,
you know,
build these,
build it.
It's a land grab and the eye.
Everyone believed that it was,
the Internet was a land grabbing.
You had to build this thing.
We built a 20,000 orders at a pick pack
center to automatically fulfill wine.
And it was a thing of beauty.
I'm built it from Greenfield to pull
production in six months.
Had 15 bays for big ups trucks to back
up into and you know,
it never got to ship much wine.
And um,
you know,
it did actually,
uh,
those assets were restarted by Kleiner
and a new company called new vine
logistics which did ship line in the
back end for winery clubs and what have
you.
But it was never,
never the,
the opportunity that we all believed it
would be.
Um,
and you know,
other mistakes.
I mean,
you make hiring mistakes,
you make,
um,
a strategic mistakes.
You had an opportunity to merge with a
company earlier in wine,
a wine shoppers history that I did
pursue.
Hindsight is 20 slash 20,
I should have pursued it.
Um,
but you know,
each time you get smarter and um,
the other thing you learn to do is you
don't fret over your mistakes,
you just interest instantly correct and
move on.
You make a bad hire,
you gotta make the decision to say,
listen,
this isn't right.
It's not working out and you cut and run
and you and hire someone else.
So,
you know,
as long as you can act decisively,
you can,
um,
uh,
undo the effects of bad decisions.
But I think we all make that decisions.
Um,
the fact is,
if you never made any bad decisions,
you probably weren't taking any risks.
Yeah,
fundraising is hard right now.
I'm a angels have their personal net
worth have been depleted in some cases
not depleted,
but certainly reduced where they're less
willing to take risks.
Um,
the vcs,
some vcs have had trouble closing new
funds.
I mean,
the top vcs have money to spend and
there's plenty of money that's being
spent and invested.
Um,
the way I think of it is,
um,
well in terms of the stages,
it will almost always is going to be
credit card debt and friends and family
initially.
Um,
it's very rare that you're going to go
right out of whatever your ideas pop
into Kleiner Perkins and they're going
to write you a check.
You're going to have to prove something
before you can typically raise money
from a vc and the four areas that you,
they look at,
there's four areas of risk and,
and investing is all about risk versus
reward.
So they want as least as little risk for
the most reward.
So they're going to try and reduce that
risk.
So there's management,
risk,
market risk,
financial risk,
and technology risk.
So Management Risk,
if you've never run a company before,
you'll do much better going into pitch a
VC.
If you've already got two or three
seasoned people who have run the types
of functions,
you need them to run and done it
successfully on your team.
So that reduces management risk.
People in the company who've done it
before,
um,
you don't have to do all four of these,
but you have to hit to,
you know,
typically hit depending on the investing
climate to two to four.
So market risk is,
is there a market for your product?
What's the competitive landscape?
Is it,
you know,
a billion dollar opportunity because vcs
typically they want to see at least a
billion dollar addressable market.
That doesn't mean you can't start a
company.
Um,
uh,
if it doesn't have an addressable market
of a billion dollars,
it just means it's probably not a vc
play.
It's probably a different type of
business and you don't have to attract
venture to build a great business.
As many people know.
I'm the third one was financial risk,
which is,
is there a business model?
Can you actually make money,
you know,
is there a way for this business to
sustain itself and be profitable?
And the fourth is technology risk,
which if your,
um,
company involves some kind of new
technology or new thing,
have you built one and proven that it
can be done.
And,
you know,
during the bubble days,
like in,
in 1998,
99 when it was really crazy,
you could probably only have to tick off
one of those boxes to get vc funding.
I'm now,
uh,
you probably need to tick off pretty
probably all four,
maybe three.
And you know,
and market and mitigating market risk
means having paying customers,
right?
So that's not always the case.
Certainly in the past few years there's
been a rush of money sent into social
media stuff.
But,
um,
uh,
you know,
the more that you can sort of address
those four issues and do it in a very
convincing way through data,
through,
you know,
um,
Beta customers through a letters of
intent,
whatever you can do to sort of increase
the likelihood that you're going to be
able to execute is going to improve your
chances of getting funded.
It's very hard.
Hiring is the most important job of the
CEO.
And it's the hardest in many ways
because if you think about it,
first of all,
the screening process is broken,
right?
And you get an email on a resume and
you're supposed to figure out who this
person is.
So clearly the screening process means
you're leaving some good people behind
and,
and not so,
you know,
obviously that's the whole purpose of
using your network.
If you can find someone who you are
somehow connected with that sort of is
the prescreening process either through
someone.
So that helps with the screening.
Um,
you know,
I,
different people look for different
things.
I've,
you know,
part of the reason I'm an entrepreneurs
that um,
I am not a political animal.
I don't think I could ever succeed quite
frankly in a big enterprise where,
in my opinion,
and this may be unfair to people in big
enterprises where half the battle of
getting ahead is playing the political
game correctly.
It's not purely about the best ideas.
And I'm in a startup environment,
you get a chance to see your ideas tried
very quickly and it's not about who you
play golf with.
And so when I'm hiring,
I try to look for people who have
succeeded environments where politics
probably wasn't part of their success.
And there's ways to read that.
You can read it and body language and
answers to certain questions.
Um,
but I really try to wean out the
political animals and focus on people
who are really good,
not just really politically savvy.
And the other thing I do is I,
um,
you know,
I think it's very important to ask them
some questions that,
uh,
are more on the human side,
not just the work,
the work stuff is a given.
Do they have the skills,
you're going to get that out of the way
pretty quickly.
But then you've got a sort of,
is this someone I want to work with is
as someone I can trust,
is this someone who's a team player?
And one of the things I did with my
first company actually would,
would wine shop or was
I the condition of being hired was that
everyone was gonna make the same base
salary and it was going to be low.
And you know,
this is when,
you know,
with Kleiner Perkins and Amazon backing
us,
there are a lot of people who were
coming to us with dollar signs in their
eyes.
And I said,
I want to weed out the people that are
really passionate about this
opportunity,
so I'm going to only offer for these
art.
And these were people from becoming
seasoned people.
I'm going to only offer $130,000 in
salary.
I'll take that salary and everyone will
get the same salary and for the first
year everyone's going to get the same
salary and that after that there'll be
more merit based.
And,
and that was really effective at
building a cohesive team because one,
people who were in it just for the
money,
that was a turnoff for them and they
were out the door,
they never even applied.
And then
everyone felt like there's this whole
sort of survey or salary envy thing that
can happen in a management team.
Like how come that person getting paid
more than if everyone knows that
everybody's paid the same.
Then it sort of breaks down that one
potential for,
um,
a tension in the office.
And it worked right?
Rebuilt at a wine shop or it was
probably the best management team I've
ever built.
I mean,
it really was an excellent team and um,
so it,
it,
it's a tough process though and um,
you do have to move quickly when you
make mistake.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
where it has mostly been in the
opportunity with to bond with people in
the industry.
Certainly in the bay area where I
started most of my businesses,
it's really a nonissue and in fact it
can even be a plus because there's so
much networking within the gay world
there.
But I'm like,
there was an instance where,
um,
a couple,
you know,
a guy who was very senior at facebook
and is moved on to an even bigger role
elsewhere as a guy.
Really good guy to know.
Very smart guy.
I've known him for 10 years and um,
you know,
he and another guy I know and,
and I went on kind of the stag trip to
Las Vegas and,
and,
um,
I didn't,
I wasn't invited and didn't know about
it and found out afterwards and it was
fine,
but,
you know,
I think they wouldn't have felt
comfortable with me being there because
it was kind of a stag male bonding thing
and um,
and I probably wouldn't have been
comfortable in it.
The other thing that happens is
increasingly I've chosen not to have
kids.
I realize you can have kids as a,
as a gay adult,
but I've chosen not to and I'm
increasingly people's lives centered
around their families and social
calendars.
So there's,
I think there's just stuff that maybe
I'm not as connected with people because
I don't up play dates with their kids
and my kids and all that kind of stuff.
So there's some social aspects maybe
that I missed out on,
but there's never been any sort of
problem with anyone finding out that I
was gay and suddenly not wanting to do
business with me or not wanting to fund
me or,
you know,
in fact,
typically what happens because I was
afraid to tell people,
but when I finally told people that have
wine shop or um,
the management team,
it was amazing.
It really was amazing and I was in a
fraternity in college and,
you know,
have learned how to sort of fit into a
very male dominant dominated environment
and was just fine at it.
Um,
so I tend to just slip into that.
But,
you know,
what I don't do anymore is I don't feign
interest in sports because I'm simply
not.
And I don't feign interest in girls
because I'm simply not.
Um,
and so whereas up until maybe even 10
years ago,
I would sort of,
you know,
jump in on those conversations and it
just felt so wrong.
Right?
So I think that was,
that's the only issues is maybe just
missing out on some bonding
opportunities with people that are
straight oriented,
like family stuff and stuff.
But other than that,
I'm not really an issue.
You know,
I thought I looked at that question and
um,
you know,
I,
my favorite business icon is steve jobs
in terms of my role model.
Um,
and he's not gay,
but,
um,
I couldn't,
I couldn't think of anyone in the
business world that I knew was gay and
that I think is telling right because
I'm sure that some of these very
successful business people that are out
there are gay,
but they're not out.
And so that's why it's difficult to
answer that question.
I'm in the business world because,
you know,
I know I'm
confidentially,
so I won't say.
But I can think of five major household
name companies where I know either the
CEO or very senior people who are gay
and um,
but they're very careful about it.
And so,
uh,
you know,
I think the business world is kind of
the last frontier I think for,
um,
uh,
that kind of diversity to really take
hold.
Um,
and it's,
it's a,
um,
I don't know,
it's,
it's interesting.
It also is very regional.
I think if you're in,
it's big difference if you're trying to
do business in perhaps a more
conservative part of the country than it
would be if you're doing business in San
Francisco in New York.
We're really,
it is completely anon issue.
It's just a relevant.
Yeah,
there are issues.
I mean,
certainly,
um,
I think in the,
in the Arab world for example,
I think it'd be very challenging.
Um,
and uh,
China,
I don't know as much about views on
homosexuality,
but I imagine not great.
Um,
you know,
the bottom line is that business,
unless you're in the sex business,
there is no reason to mix sex and
business and I'm just like in the
straight world,
it would be inappropriate in a meeting
to discuss your fetishes or,
or something like that.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
your wife and all,
you just don't talk about it.
And so it,
it really doesn't need to be relevant
and it doesn't need to be discussed.
And it would be weird.
I actually,
um,
I've always been of the belief that I
should just be myself and um,
if someone asks me,
are you gay,
I'll,
I will answer them honestly,
but I'm not going to broadcast that
necessarily.
Um,
because it's,
uh,
it's,
it's a personal characteristic of me.
Um,
I was made this way and it's nothing
that everybody I need to rub in
everybody's face.
I mean,
it's just a,
it's an,
it's an aspect of me.
I have no problems with it.
I'm proud of myself,
but it isn't something I need to wear on
my sleeve.
And so I just can't think of,
you know,
in 20 years of doing business in some
form,
I can't think of any situation where
it's ever come up in any kind of meeting
with,
you know,
big companies,
Sony,
Dell,
staples,
all sorts of big corporations.
I've met with a New York Times,
you know,
and it just never comes up,
which is great.
Yeah.